je parle exactement comme j'en parle et
rit jaune ça fait 20 ans qu'on habite
ici ça fait 20 ans que tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours on a des
quarts des juifs avec des discours de
judée cérémonie ce bulletin d allumage
de bouche du jeu robuste du juif
paternité et soir excuse moi me bouge un
peu plus moi ici je je verrai un mec
mais c'est pas une raison pour monter le
son du téléviseur
le concierge a vu la voisine elle
partait au commissariat déposer une
plainte je te signale le col de pause
d'un dépôt de plainte
grand bien lui fasse mon avis je vais
déposer plainte contre la base in non
content les juifs quand tous ces juifs
qui me pourrissent des clans mais moi
comme si les juifs étaient les seuls de
l'histoire de l'humanité avoir souffert
à seyssins froeliger un risque viennent
sont les seuls non je crois pas est ce
que les juifs ont le monopole de la
souffrance répond moi et quoi les noirs
les arabes les gitans les italiens les
arménien à l'ailé polak toujours pas
souffert eux ils n'ont pas souffert et
moi je n'ai pas souffert mais qu'elle
souffre de quoi rougir
j'ai souffert
il vous fait d'eux des trous secondes